good morning he gets Friday so our tour
ended last night in Los Angeles almost
every night for the last month I've
stood at the side of the stage during
your set and watched you play because I
love your music and I love watching you
perform it and also because it brings
back memories I think about the first
time I saw you play in front of a crowd
45 people in Grand Rapids Michigan
almost a decade ago now or I think about
other nights Edinboro the first VidCon
or 8808 in Chicago when Harry Potter
fans were singing your song so loudly I
could barely hear your voice over theirs
and I think about how later that night
in 2008 we hung out with Amy Krauss
Rosenthal my friend who died earlier
this year here's an Amy story I've been
telling on tour so back in 2005 Amy who
was a children's book writer and
memoirist and professional seeker of
wonder in the world invited me to one of
her readings and at the time I was in
one of my periods of intense unwellness
I felt like I was losing my whole self
to intrusive thought spirals but this
particular episode was accompanied by a
chest crushing depression I found
nothing enjoyable I struggled to get out
of bed
the usual it was at once absolutely
excruciating and completely boring Susan
Sontag wrote that depression is
melancholy - its charms somehow I
managed to get to the event but I wasn't
having much fun at it because I was
alone and I was stuck with these
invasive thoughts I couldn't stop having
and also Amy kept wanting people to
participate in what she was doing and I
hate audience participation it just
makes me very nervous because one
sometimes the audience doesn't deliver
and also - I have paid for the show to
be entertained not to be part of the
entertainment
so anyway I was just in a terrible mood
and then seemingly out of nowhere Amy
started talking about how back in World
War one all of these British soldiers
who didn't understand why they were
being asked to fight and die for tiny
patches of ground far from their home
started singing a song to the tune of
that New Year's Eve song auld lang syne
they would sing we're here because we're
here because we're here because we're
here it was this recursive lament an
acknowledgment that there was no why
that life in the trenches was
meaninglessness all the way down but
that night in 2005
Amy completely transformed that song for
me without ever changing the words Amy
made me understand that
we were here meaning that we were
together and even when we felt alone we
weren't really because we were part of
this vast and deeply interconnected us
and also that we were here even if only
for a little while and maybe we'll never
know why we are here but we can still
proclaim in hope that we are here that
night Amy made me understand that hope
is not foolish or idealistic or
misguided hope is true and I really
believe that I really believe that hope
is the correct response to the arc of
history thank some years are longer than
others and 2017 has been a long one for
me it's been good and bad and difficult
and amazing and joyful and terrifying
and very long but we're here we're here
Hank I'll see you on Monday and now hey
William yeah I'm extremely scared
somebody has a laptop with him I'm
getting kind of tired this publication
hold the gun and reserve the reserve
copy on Amazon now any morning well
skirt you cell
give me my burger gotta
[Music]
that's